he7 so i was like i don't know david
i would ignore it and i think wesley
agreed with me as well but this does
look a little bit like oh
i mean it's ugly
oh wow the bar just shot up yeah the bar
was gonna hate it because i mean just
look at it you know putting the queen on
a terrible square and uh there's no
coordination whatsoever um with the
black pieces but okay
yeah
instinctively we both said it was ugly
right that's because you're putting your
queen on a bad square you're just
putting her on a passive square she's
only defending the bishop in front of
her you're still not dealing with the
problem of that white knight that really
strong white knight it just feels like
the kind of move that you you know last
resort if you have nothing else this is
the type of move you play in the
computer we did see it get a bit excited
but there's nothing direct here there's
no knockout blow for white that's why
magnus just improves his queen queens
love being in the centre of the board
compared the queens right now white's
queen hitting pawns hitting the black
knight black's queen terribly passive um
so magnus very sensibly there just
improving his queen and now i think
wesley what's he going to do he has to
get rid of that knight at some point is
it now does he leave it one move longer
struggling to see ways to maintain the
tension here
yeah well he has to do something about
his knight that's under attack so i mean
there are two kind of ways i could think
about you could deal with that you could
maybe improve the position of the rook
um just move it to the d8 square so
that's that stops knight takes night um
so just to pin yeah
white knight to the white queen and
that's one thing that i would perhaps do
but then okay
white's move i think is pretty natural
is also to improve their own work
if you capture it ah
you're still reluctant
i don't like it what can i say
it doesn't come easily to me to give a
gift quite such a beautiful pawn